i'd like to start by saying the events
of last week
for paul sarah and her family were
absolutely ghastly
um just a horrible horrible
set of events which i think has touched
the whole nation i know i can speak for
my people
when i say this incredible strength of
feeling of
anger and sadness and a real
determination to you know get justice
for sarah
um and in the last couple of days i've
been out with my investigation teams my
search teams my friends teams my
neighborhood teams all the women and men
of the met are outraged at what has
happened
and they're working as hard as they can
to get justice for sarah
in that context none of us would have
wanted
uh to see the scenes we saw
at the end of yesterday's events
worth saying um of course i
fully understand the strength of feeling
i think as a woman and
hearing from people about their
experiences in the past and what they
feel about
uh what happened to sarah and what has
been going on i understand why
so many people wanted to come and pay
their respects
and kind of make a statement about this
indeed
if it had been lawful i'd have been
there i'd have been at a vigil
um and six hours
of yesterday was really calm
and peaceful very few police officers
around
respectful people laying flowers
not gathering and you know a vigil
that did not breach the regulations
unfortunately
later on we had a really big
crowd that gathered lots of speeches
and quite rightly
as far as i can see my team felt this is
now
an unlawful gathering which poses a
considerable risk to people's health
according to the regulations uh a really
invidious position for my officers to
find themselves in
but they then moved to try to explain to
people to engage with people to get
people to disperse
from this unlawful gathering and many
many many people did
unfortunately a small minority did not
the mayor called those scenes completely
unacceptable home secretary described
them as upsetting
when you saw those pictures did you
agree did you think it was unacceptable
the way in which your officers
acted i wouldn't have wanted to see a
vigil
in memory of sarah and
with those scenes and that's why
this morning i said
from what i can tell i wasn't there
but from what i can tell my officers in
a very difficult position
as they have been again and again in the
last year
policing within the coronavirus
restrictions
having to uphold the law having to be
impartial
having to be fair but of course
trying to apply you know common sense
and
discretion and if people don't
understand the law
trying to help them to understand and
engage and engage and speak and speak
before we ever
turn to any enforcement but that is why
i said we didn't want it to end like
that
let's have a review so i welcome the
fact
that this appears now the home secretary
i believe has asked for
the hmi to review it i've spoken
in the day to both the home secretary
and the mayor i'm very comfortable with
that and i think my officers will be as
well
they it seems they were not comfortable
with your reasoning they've both come
out and said they're not satisfied
with that meeting and the responses and
answers you have given the home
secretary
believes there are still questions to be
answered the mayor said he's not
satisfied
so i i can't speak for them and you've
interpreted what
they have said what i've said
what i can say is that i think it would
be good
for public confidence for this
uh policing operation in the context
that it was taking place
in the round given of course the
extraordinary strength of feeling that
there
was at the time but also given the fact
that we're still in a pandemic
unlawful gatherings are unlawful
gatherings officers have to take
action uh if people are putting
themselves massively at risk
what we do in one event sets precedent
for other events
i am really comfortable that we
review what happened i don't think
anybody
who was not in the operation can
actually
pass a detailed comment on
the rightness and wrongness of it you
know this is
fiendishly difficult policing but also
i'm sure for the people who wanted
to you know express their feelings that
was a
difficult situation for them and and
that's why
it needs a cold light of day sober
review and i think we're all agreed on
that
there have been calls from all quarters
uh
many quarters for you to resign are you
considering your position
no i'm not what happened to sarah
appalls me as you know i'm the first
woman commissioner i've met perhaps
it appalls me in a way even more because
of that
what has happened makes me more
determined
not less to lead my organization
i've listened to what people have been
saying in the last week i know
that in the streets all across the uk
women
don't feel as safe as we would all like
women to feel
i am utterly determined we've done an
awful lot in the last three years to
bring down violence
to for example set up our predatory
offender units
get nasty violence all male i may say
people arrested and charged for horrible
violence against women
but there must be more we as the mac can
do there must be more the criminal
justice system can do
and there must be more wider society can
do to ensure that women can walk around
our streets
being safer than they are now and
feeling safer than they are now
so my view is i'm entirely focused on
that
i'm focused on growing the met to be
even stronger and even better together
with others
at keeping women safe and that's my job
right now growing the mess
just one more growing the met is going
to be much harder given what's happened
in terms of reputational damage do you
feel you owe an apology to your
frontline officers who
are bearing the brunt of some of the the
fury
and the and the feeling that is out
there at the moment
i feel for my officers i feel for them
every day i've
just told you i've been out with them uh
a great deal in the last 36 hours that's
what this that's the sort of
commissioner i
am i completely recognise that they are
particularly in this last year often
finding themselves in
very very difficult situations they are
policing during a pandemic
nobody wants a third wave to happen it's
only a few
weeks since the nhs was on its knees
they have a
really difficult job they have to make
fine judgments they often don't have
infinite information or all the time in
the world
they have to make these really difficult
calls
and i don't think anybody should be
sitting back in an
armchair and saying well that was done
badly or i would have done it
differently
without actually understanding what they
was going through their minds i
guarantee
that every single officer who was
policing last night like me
would rather we would not in the time of
coronavirus there could be
a large peaceful set of vigils all over
the country
and most of them would have been at
those vigils and i guarantee also
that my officers up and down london and
beyond
if they weren't working will have been
thinking of sarah at 9 30 last night
they will have been lighting their
candles or pausing and
it's something we care about very very
deeply